GOING DOWN.
AND THAT IS VERY GOOD NEWS.
LET’S BRING IN NEWT GINGRICH, IS
HE A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, HE
JOINS US FROM ROME, ACTUALLY.
MR. SPEAKER, I’M SURE YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW THERE IS
A LOT OF FRUSTRATION.
A LOT PEOPLE WANT TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THESE STAY AT
HOME ORDERS FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
SO THAT THE CURVE GOES DOWN AND
PEOPLE CAN EVENTUALLY GO BACK TO
WORK AND ALL OF THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING EVENTUALLY GOES AWAY.
BUT, CAN YOU UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN MONTANA VERSUS THE PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT BE HERE IN NEW JERSEY
BECAUSE YOU ARE IN A HOT SPOT.
YOU ARE IN ROME.
>> SURE.
LOOK, THE VIRUS GOT TO BE SO BAD
IN ITALY BUT THEY HAD NO CHOICE
EXCEPT TO CLOSE VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING.
AND IT’S BEEN PRETTY STRICT NOW
FOR ABOUT 6 OR 7 WEEKS.
STEVE: YEAH.
IF YOU LEAVE YOUR HOUSE.
YOU CAN’T GO MORE THAN
200 METERS EVEN TO WALK YOUR DOG
OR WHATEVER.
YOU CAN’T BE IN GROUPS OF LARGER
THAN TWO.
YOU CAN BE FINED $3,200 IF THE
POLICE FIND YOU ON A STREET
WITHOUT AN APPROPRIATE REASON.
THEY HAVE GAS STATIONS OPEN.
PHARMACIES, GROCERY STORES.
THAT’S IT.
NOW, FOR 17 STRAIGHT DAYS, THEY
HAVE HAD A STEADY, SLOW DECLINE
IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE GOING
INTO INTENSIVE CARE UNITS.
AND IT IS BEGINNING TO BE SOME
OPTIMISM THAT WE ARE VERY, VERY
CLOSE TO REACHING A PLATEAU AND
STARTING DOWNWARD.
I THINK THEY ARE BEGINNING TO
STORES OPEN, A FREE THINGS HERE.
TELL US ABOUT ITALY.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS REOPEN
STORES THAT FIX COFFEE MACHINES.
BECAUSE WITHOUT EXPRESS SO HE EX
OTHER ITALIAN COFFEES.
HOW CAN ONE LIVE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS PERFECT
ITALIAN SOLUTION.
VERY CAREFUL AND SLOW.
TWO THINGS GOING ON.
FIRST OF ALL, THE UNITED STATES
IS A GIGANTIC COUNTRY.
IT’S BIGGER THAN ALL OF EUROPE.
SO, WHAT’S RIGHT FOR MONTANA OR
TEXAS OR WHAT’S RIGHT FOR WEST
TEXAS VS. HOUSTON, ARE DIFFERENT
THINGS.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS VERY
WISE TO DECENTRALIZE, DELEGATE
AND GIVE THE GOVERNORS AN
ASSIGNMENT.
SECOND, I THINK.
SO GOVERNORS HAVE SHOWN THEIR
IDEOLOGICAL BIAS SO THAT ONE
GOVERNOR, FOR EXAMPLE, SAID IT
WAS OKAY FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD
TO STAY OPEN FOR ABORTIONS BUT
IT WASN’T OKAY FOR THE CHURCHES
TO HAVE SERVICES.
WELL, THAT’S CLEARLY JUST AN
IDEOLOGICAL ABUSE OF EMERGENCY.
I THINK THAT’S PART OF WHAT HAS
PEOPLE WITH THEIR TEETH ON EDGE
BECAUSE THEY’RE WATCHING
POLITICIANS ABUSE THEIR POWER.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
GO BACK TO WORK SLOWLY,
CAREFULLY.
LEARN LESSONS.
I MEAN, IF SOUTH DAKOTA AND
NORTH DAKOTA FOR EXAMPLE WORKING
FOR SANFORD HEALTH AND OTHERS,
DECIDES THAT THEY’RE GRADUALLILY
GOING TO OPEN UP.
LET’S LEARN FROM WHAT WORKS AND
DOESN’T WORK.
ONE STATE SHOULD STUDY EVERY
OTHER STATE AS THEY GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND COUPLE MONTHS
WE WILL BE DRAMATICALLY FURTHER
DOWN THE ROAD.
AINSLEY: I KNOW YOU ADDRESSED
MANY OF THESE ISSUES ON YOUR
OP-ED ON FOXNEWS.COM.
THE HEADLINE IS CORONAVIRUS
CRISIS MAKES SOME LEADERS
BELIEVE THAT THEY HAVE GOD-LIKE
DECISION MAKING CAPACITY.
LUV EXPLAIN THAT?
WHICH LEADERS ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
>> GOVERNOR OF MICHIGAN TRULY
ABSURD EXECUTIVE ORDER
SUGGESTING THAT YOU COULDN’T BUY
A CHILD SEAT YOU COULDN’T BUY
SEEDS.
IF YOU WENT TO WALMART OR HOME
DEPOT THE AREA THAT SOLD SEEDS
TO PLANT IN YOUR BACKYARD HAD A
SIGN UP THAT SAID IT’S ILLEGAL
TO BUY THESE RIGHT NOW.
NORMAL PEOPLE -- WHAT IS THAT
ALL ABOUT?
LOOKS AT THE LIST YOU SORT OF
GET SOME INTERN MUST HAVE
WRITTEN IT UP BECAUSE IT MAKES
SO LITTLE SENSE.
THAT’S AN EXAMPLE.
YOU HAD A MAYOR IN ILLINOIS WHO
DECLARED THAT SHE HAD THE RIGHT
TO DECIDE WHO COULD GET FOOD AND
WHO COULDN’T GET FOOD.
THE KIND OF THINGS LORD ACHE
WORN US POWER TO CORRUPT
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU LOOK AROUND THE COUNTRY, ONE
OF THE MAJOR RESPONSIBILITIES
RIGHT AFTER DEFEATING THE VIRUS
AND RESTARTING THE ECONOMY.
THIRD BIG EFFORT IS GOING TO BE
TO TAKE POWER BACK FROM THE
POLITICIANS YOU CANNOT ALLOW
THEM TO DECIDE THEY ARE LITTLE
PETTY GODS WHO GET TO DECIDE
LIFE AND DEATH FOR THE REST OF
US.
BRIAN: THE DEMOCRATIC LEADER HER
WORK MIGHT BE DOING HER BEST
MICHIGAN AGAIN.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" DID A STORY
ON HER.
DIDN’T EVEN BRING UP THE 52
EXECUTIVE ORDERS LIKE DON’T BUY
PAINT.
YOU CAN’T USE A MOTOR BOLT YOU
CAN USE A KAYAK.
THEY DIDN’T PUT THAT IN THE
STORY.
FOUR SHERIFFS SAID WE ARE NOT
GOING FOR THIS. FOR NANCY PELOSI
IN ON WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS
DOING.
NO SURPRISE TO ANYBODY NOT VERY
GOOD TO HER.
>> DON’T YOU BELIEVE DR. FAUCI.
>> YEAH.
HE SAID IF THIS WERE DONE
PROPERLY.
IT HASN’T BEEN DONE.
MARCH 4TH WE PASSED OUR FIRST
BILL BIPARTISAN.
TESTING, TESTING, TESTING.
IT’S OVER SIX WEEKS SINCE THEN
AND IT HASN’T BEEN DONE.
WE ARE WAY LATE ON IT.
AND THAT IS A FAILURE.
THE PRESIDENT GETS AN F, FAILURE
ON THE TESTING.
DR. FAUCI IS RIGHT IF IT’S DONE
PROPERLY.
IT HASN’T BEEN.
I THINK THAT PUTS IT IN THE IF
IT IS DONE IS AN ADMISSION THAT
IT HASN’T BEEN DONE.
BRIAN: SHE SAT THERE BY HER
MULTI-MILLION-DOLLAR
REFRIGERATORS AND MADE THOSE
COMMENTS.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> I WROTE MINUS LETTER FRIDAY
ON THE JOB KILLING ICE CREAM
EATING DEMOCRATS.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THE WHOLE
NOTION OF NANCY PELOSI HOLDING
UP AID TO SMALL BUSINESS WHILE
SHE STOOD IN FRONT OF HER.
BRIAN: UNBELIEVABLE.
>> TWO VERY EXPENSIVE
REFRIGERATORS HOW SHE LOVES TO
HAVE HER $11.75 A PINT ICE CREAM
COMFORTS HER.
MOST TONE DEAF THING I HAVE EVER
SEEN A SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE DO.
I SERVED WITH TIPP O’NEAL AND
JIM WRIGHT AND TOM FOLLY AND OF
COURSE I WORKED WITH DENNY
HASTERT AND JOHN BAY NORTHWARD
AND PAUL RYAN, THIS WAS GOOFY
EVEN BY SAN FRANCISCO STANDARDS.
IT WAS GOOFY.
THE FACT IS THE PRESIDENT HAS
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
DR. FAUCIY.
DR. FAUCI SAYS SO EVERY TIME HE
IS ASKED BY THE PRESS.
HE AND DR. BIRX BOTH HAVE VERY
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS.
THEY HAVE BEEN ADVISING THE
PRESIDENT.
IN THE END, LOOK, THE REASON YOU
HAVE A PRESIDENT IS THERE ARE
SOME DECISIONS LARGER THAN
EXPERTS.
AND IT’S THE JOB OF THE
PRESIDENT TO WEIGH EVERYTHING.
AND THEN TRY TO MAKE THE BEST
POSSIBLE DECISION.
I WOULD SAY OVERALL YOU LOOK AT
OUR FATALITY RATE AND YOU LOOK
AT EUROPE, CAN YOU FEEL PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE.
STEVE: NEWT, I’M SURE YOU SAW.
SO VIDEO OF THE VARIOUS PROTESTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY REGARDING THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS.
IN ONE OF THE BIG ONES WAS IN
DENVER COLORADO YESTERDAY, AND
"THE DENVER POST" TALKED TO A
FELLOW BY THE NAME OF JIM
FENNIMORE.
HE SAID THAT HE THINKS THE
DEMOCRATS ARE USING THE
CORONAVIRUS AS A POLITICAL TOOL
HE SAID TO CRASH THE ECONOMY AND
HURT THE PRESIDENT SO THAT HE
LOSES.
YOU DON’T THINK THERE ARE
POLITICS LIKE THAT INVOLVED IN
THESE CALCULATIONS, DO YOU?
>> LOOK, TO BE HONEST, I DON’T
THINK THAT SCHUMER AND PELOSI
MIND OR THAT BIDEN MINDS IF THE
ECONOMY DOESN’T QUITE RECOVER
RAPIDLY.
I MEAN, THEY ARE FACED WITH A
NIGHTMARE.
THE PRESIDENT FINISHES HANDLING
THE CORONAVIRUS AS WELL AS I
THINK HE WILL.
AND HE THEN PIVOTS AND USES ALL
OF HIS ABDUL ABILITY TO CREATE A
STRONG ECONOMY AND BY SEPTEMBER
AND OCTOBER YOU CAN TELL THAT
WE’RE COMING BACK, THE ELECTION
WILL BE OVER AND TRUMP WILL GET
REELECTED.
IF YOU ARE PELOSI AND SCHUMER.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT COME
BACK, SAY, NEXT JANUARY BUT NOT
THIS SEPTEMBER.
AND I’M NOT SAYING THAT THEY SIT
DOWN IN A COLDLY CALCULATED WAY.
BUT I DON’T THINK THAT THEY HAVE
AT ANY POINT PLACED PUTTING
AMERICA BACK TO WORK AHEAD OF
PARTISAN POLITICS.
AND THAT’S WHY, FOR A WEEK NOW.
THEY HAVE SCREWED UP THE SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS WHICH CLEARLY
HURTS BECAUSE SMALL BUSINESS
CREATES THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
NEW JOBS IN AMERICA AND YOU HAVE
A LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES
SAYING, LOOK, I HAVE GOT ABOUT A
WEEK TO GO IF I CAN’T GET
FINANCING.
AND THEY JUST SAT ON IT.
YOU TELL ME.
WHY THAT IS NOT FRANKLY A
REMARKABLY DESTRUCTIVE THING
THEY ARE GOING TO BE DO.
AINSLEY: MR. SPEAKER, WHY DID
THEY DO THAT?
WHY ARE THEY MAKING THIS
POLITICAL DIDN’T PASS THE LAST
PROPOSAL?
IS IT BECAUSE THEY DON’T WANT
THE PRESIDENT TO HAVE A WIN?
DON’T THEY WANT TO PUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AHEAD OF
ANYTHING ELSE?
>> LOOK, I THINK THEY ARE
ENGAGED IN A GAME OF CHICKEN.
THEY HAVE DONE THIS NOW SEVERAL
TIMES.
AND THEIR HOPE IS AT SOME POINT
THAT THE PRESIDENT OR SECRETARY
MNUCHIN OR SOMEBODY WILL FLINCH
AND GIVE THEM WHAT THEY WANT.
AND I THINK THAT OVERALL AND I
GIVE SENATOR MITCH McCONNELL A
GREAT DEAL OF CREDIT FOR THIS.
WHEN HE PASSED THE VERY LARGE
2.2 TRILLION-DOLLAR AID PACKAGE
BY 96-0.
HE TOOK ALL OF THE WIND OUT OF
PELOSI’S SALES.
IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE FOR HER AT
THAT POINT TO BLOCK ANYTHING.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS SERIOUS.
IS NOT A GAME.
A SPEAKER TO NEGOTIATED WITH A
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT YOU START
OUT HOW FAR CAN I PUSH HIM.
OF COURSE WITH TRUMP NOT VERY
FAR.
I THINK ON THESE ISSUES, THEY
ARE SO FAR OUT OF SYNC WITH THE
COUNTRY VERY DESTRUCTIVE TO PLAY
THESE GAMES.
THEY HAVE NO CHOICE.
THEIR LEFT WILL NOT TOLERATE
THEM COOPERATING WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
BRIAN: GOTCHA.
ALL RIGHT, THE OTHER THING I
WANT TO BRING YOU TO AND BEFORE
WE GET TO WHAT JEH JOHNSON JUST
TOLD US AS THE DEMOCRATIC -- AS
A DEMOCRAT -- HE WAS FORMER
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY,
JUST FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE, YOU
HAD A LOT OF EUROPEAN COUNTRIES
ABOUT TO GET IN BED WITH CHINA
WITH THIS BELTON ROAD PROGRAM
AND BUYING 5G FROM HUAWEI.
AFTER THE REALITY OF WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE IN DESTROYING 180
NAILS’ ECONOMY AND KILLING SO
MANY FROM THE IRRESPONSIBLE
BEHAVIOR WHEN THIS CAME TO THIS
VIRUS, DO YOU BELIEVE THE
ITALIANS ARE RETHINKING THAT
ALLIANCE AND DO YOU BELIEVE
BEYOND GERMANY ALREADY
REGISTERED THEIR DISDAIN.
DO YOU BELIEVE OTHER COUNTRIES
ARE, TOO?
>> YES.
I THINK THIS HAS BEEN A
STUNNINGLY EYE OPENING
EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE A PAPER THAT WILL COME
OUT THIS WEEK POINTING OUT BASED
REALLY ON THE HUDSON INSTUDY’S
REMARKABLE TIMELINE THEY
PRODUCED A TIMELINE ALL THE WAY
BACK TO NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR.
IT’S DEVASTATING.
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTH HAMPTON
ESTIMATES THAT IF THE CHINESE
HAD BEEN HONEST.
95% OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED
WOULD STILL BE ALIVE.
NOW, THAT IS -- THINK ABOUT
THAT.
OVER 160,000 DEAD AND ACCORDING
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTH
HAMPTON, 95% OF THOSE PEOPLE
DIED BECAUSE THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP
DELIBERATELY LIED AND GOT ITS
PUPPET AT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION TO DELIBERATELY
LIE.
AND I THINK, FRANKLY THAT WE
SHOULD TAKE SIGNIFICANT STEPS,
ONE WHICH WOULD EFFECT ITALY
WHICH WROTE ABOUT AND I THOUGHT
WAS BRILLIANT.
SIMPLY MOVE THE WINTER OLYMPICS
IN 20022 BACK TO ITALY WHICH
HOSTED IT I THINK IN 2002 AND
ALLOW TURIN, AT THE VERY CENTER
OF THE AREA THAT HAD BEEN
SAVAGED BY THE CHINESE TO ALLOW
TURIN TO HOST THE OLYMPICS NEXT
YEAR THAT WOULD BE THE KIND OF
GESTURE THAT WOULD BEGIN TO
COMMUNICATE THE WORLD IS FED UP
WITH THE WAY THE DICTATORSHIP
OPERATORS.
NO QUESTION THE CHINESE
DICTATORSHIP HAS COST THE WORLD
BY THE TIME IT’S DONE, THEY WILL
HAVE COST THE WORLD SEVERAL
HUNDRED THOUSAND LIVES AND MANY,
MANY TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
AND SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE TO
HOLD THE DICTATORSHIP AND XI
JINPING AND HIS ENTIRE GROUP
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE DAMAGE THEY
HAVE DONE TO THE HUMAN RACE
WORLDWIDE.
STEVE: WELL, LET’S SEE WHAT THEY
FIGURE OUT.
MR. SPEAKER, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR JOINING US FROM ITALY.